[MUSIC PLAYING]
ADRIAN LUDWIG: Welcome
this afternoon to our talk
on Android security.
My name is Adrian.
I work on Android security.
Xiaowen will be joining us
in just a minute as well.
It's going to be a bit
of a whirlwind tour.
If I talk too fast
or Xiaowen talks too
fast I apologize,
but there's really
been a lot going on in the
world of security, on Android
and Google Play, over the
last year, the last two years,
the last five years.
And so we're going to try to
touch on quite a bit of that
as we go through here
today and give you
the information that you
hopefully need and certainly
seem to want.
We've got a lot of people
here today-- pretty exciting.
What we're going
to cover is we'll
talk a little bit about
security services and from there
hand off and begin talking
about the core operating system
and app security.
So we'll dive right in.
Yesterday we heard mention
of something new, exciting--
Google Play Protect.
What is Google Play Protect?
The core of it is
an engine that we've
built over the
last several years
to protect all of the devices
in the Android ecosystem.
This slide has grown
year after year,
and now we talk about
over 2 billion devices
around the world that are
protected by those services,
scanning over a billion
devices and checking
over 50 billion devices and the
applications every single day--
so incredible scale.
And the reason that
we have that scale
is because we need
it to be able to see
what's going on an
ecosystem that's on a mass--
really, almost the
majority of devices that
are out there in the world.
To be able to actually look at
all of that data, of course,
requires computational
resources.
Turns out Google has
quite a few of those.
We use just a tiny
sliver of them
to look at the data every day--
over 20,000 dedicated
processors that
are looking at that
application data,
analyzing it, diving deep into
every single new application
that we find over 500,000
new applications discovered
every day, and
trying to understand
how they behave in
our environment,
and how they behave out
there in the real world,
and what risks they
might pose for users.
Now the reason we do that, of
course, is to protect users.
And so one of the most
important things that we do
is try to keep an eye on
what is the risk that users
are being exposed to?
Clearly, over the last few
years, what we've found
is that users of Google Play
are in a much safer position.
They're about 95% safer if
they're installing applications
that come from Google Play.
And the reason is we're
able to use data that's
gathered outside of Google
Play and then analyze
that in the context of
an environment that's
much more controlled.
And so applications at the
time that they're uploaded--
we're able to analyze them,
understand what's in there,
and then make good guidance, and
provide that kind of guidance.
But we also provide
those protections outside
of Google Play.
And so that's what we
wanted to show here,
is that over the
last few years we've
been carefully tracking this,
keeping an eye on what's
going on, and making sure that
users are being protected.
From my perspective, it's
all about the graphs.
But that's not really how most
people think about security.
Because most people aren't
looking at the entire ecosystem
at once.
What they want to
know is, am I safe?
And so that's really what the
announcement was yesterday,
putting really in a
brand understanding
that these protections are there
and making them more and more
visible to users, but also
that Google is standing
behind this protection.
It's saying, Google is going
to protect you on your Android
device and make
sure that we have
the best protections in
place throughout the devices.
And so that's really
what we're focusing on.
How do we do that?
Well, we do that a
variety of different ways.
We're investing in increasing
the intelligence, the ability
to analyze what's going
on on these devices,
as well as what's going on
inside of these applications,
expanding the scope of the types
of protections that we provide,
and also--
quite simply-- switching
from that graph mindset
that I've latched
on to in my life
into the user mindset,
where what they want to know
is, am I being
protected right now?
Am I being protected--
what it is that
it is that Google
is doing to look out for me.
And so we've got
a lot that we're
doing in terms of
increasing user visibility.
When I talk about that
increased protection,
one of the most important
things that we've learned
is that we can't do it
all as humans, right?
When you're talking about
500,000 new applications that
are discovered and
analyzed every single day,
more and more we have to
rely upon the intelligence
of machines to be able to
do that type of analysis.
One of the largest areas
that we've been investing in
is what everybody refers
to as machine learning
or artificial intelligence.
And it's most
simplistic what it is
is it's us working with
the machines to train them.
This is a picture of a
clustering algorithm that's
grouped different types of
malware based on the behaviors
that those applications
exhibit out there in the world.
And so when we're looking
at 500,000 new applications
every day, a
clustering algorithm
gives us the ability to
quickly hone in on the ones
that we think are highest risk.
Those may be applications
that are brand new,
that no one has installed.
Those may be applications
that have been out there
for a while, that
we're starting to see
a change in their behavior.
The key is using these
systems to understand and make
those kinds of
quick decisions so
that a user doesn't
have to make them,
so that you as a developer
don't have to make them either.
And you don't have
to guess, because you
can rely upon the
investments that we're
making to analyze
all those data points
and help make those
decisions for you,
and inform you about what's
going on these devices.
The other thing that
we've begun to recognize
is sometimes we just
name things wrong.
There is a feature that we
released a couple of years ago
called Android Device Manager.
How many people had Android
Device Manager installed?
For this audience,
it's about 20%.
So you're about an
order of magnitude
higher than the overall user
base in terms of percentage
of people that had Android
Device Manager installed--
not shocking given who we are.
And how many of
you are Googlers?
No, OK.
Find my Device-- a simple way
to take an existing technology,
expose it to users,
and make it easier
for them to understand how it
is that they can get to it.
And of course, we've added
new features-- things
like battery and Wi-Fi
status, tracking the device
in the background, so that
if it gets turned off,
you know where it was
before it was turned off.
You don't have to do
the query in real time--
a number of basic
usability features
to make sure that
this functionality can
be increasingly
valuable for users.
Because after all, the
most significant security
risks that the average person
is exposed to is actually
this one, it's losing their
device, whether it's accidental
or whether it's someone
taking the device out
of their possession.
The other thing we
wanted to do is just
let people know that
this was happening.
The number of times that
I've read the statement,
Google doesn't look at the
applications in Google Play,
just blows my mind.
Every single application
that's uploaded to Google Play
goes through a very
rigorous screening process,
both at the time that the
application developer is
enrolling to become a member of
Google Play publishing process
and at the time the
application is published.
And every single
day after that, we
reanalyze all of
those applications.
So there's absolutely a lot
of that kind of intelligence
that's going on in the
background and analysis that's
going on in the background
that simply wasn't exposed.
And so a lot of the work
that we're doing right now
is to just figure out how
to delicately indicate
to the user--
whether that be a consumer
or an enterprise--
yeah, this is happening.
We're checking these things.
And we've got your back.
But it's not just
about consumers.
It's also about
application developers
and making sure that they
have the ability to leverage
these services as well.
Right now, Google Play services
is rolling out a new version.
And one of the
APIs that's exposed
is what we refer to as
the Verify Apps API.
In the past, we've
talked publicly
about Verify Apps, which
is the mechanism that's
used to evaluate on a device and
to check for a user on a device
whether something is potentially
harmful or a piece of malware.
What we've done with
the Verify Apps APIs
is just made that available to
any application on the device.
So if you're concerned
about whether or not
your application should
be running, you can check.
Are there any other
apps on this device
that I should be worried about?
What are those applications?
Let me know what they are.
And so then you can
evaluate whether or not
you think it's an appropriate
environment, as the application
developer, for your application
to continue to execute.
That builds on
other technologies
that we've provided in the past.
Last year at Google I/O I
referenced the SafetyNet
attestation API.
This is an API that
we use to evaluate,
in the context of Google's
understanding of a device,
whether it is a certified
secure Android device.
And we provide that literally
as a signed statement.
So you invoke the
attestation API.
It hits a round trip
off of a Google server.
We do an evaluation of the
software integrity on that
device, compare it to what we
know about what that device
should look like, and then
make a statement back to you
of, yep, this looks
good, or no, it doesn't.
This is one of the critical
pieces of technology
that allows for delivery of,
for example, Android Pay,
where there's a requirement
that this be a certified device
and that it be operating in
that kind of an environment.
But it's an API that we've made
available to any application
that wants to take
advantage of it.
We're going to continue adding
these kinds of technologies.
reCAPTCHA the technology
introduced almost 10 years ago
in the context of the web to
do quick evaluation of whether
or not the entity
interacting with your web UI
was actually a human.
That's now being provided
as a safety net API as well.
So in the context
of your application,
you can use a reCAPTCHA to
evaluate whether or not there's
automation of your application.
This is particularly valuable
for what I think of as low cost
services that you
want to continue
to make available for free,
but you want to cut down
on the amount of
abuse that's coming
through bot farms and
other types of automation--
very valuable for large
scale web properties.
One of the things
that's come out
of us being able to
understand what's going on
in the ecosystem is
the ability to revisit
some of the technologies
that are actually
baked into the core platform.
Unknown sources was a flag that
was introduced when Android
was launched, almost
eight years ago, that gave
the individual the ability
to change where they wanted
to install applications from.
Over the last few
years, we've begun
to understand what those
install patterns look like.
We've been able to
analyze what the risks are
that users are exposed to.
We've certainly
come to appreciate
that Google Play
is a safer place
to install applications from.
But we've also
come to appreciate
that there are many other safe
places to install applications
from as well.
And so we want to
simplify for the user
the ability to install from
those other safe places
without introducing the
risk of installing from just
anywhere that's out there.
So one of the changes that
was introduced with Android O
is a modification to how
unknown sources works.
So now it's on a per
application basis.
You decide, yep,
that app store--
it can install.
But that doesn't mean
everybody can install.
And really, that's
targeted at making sure
that apps are being installed
from more trustworthy
places, where the user has
delegated that kind of trust
to the specific entity.
So that's an example
of the types of changes
that we're making at
the platform level.
I've got Xiaowen here, I think,
who's going to come on up
and give you a
little bit of insight
into some of the
other changes we're
making to harden the
operating system.
[APPLAUSE]
XIAOWEN XIN: Thank you, Adrian.
My name is Xiaowen.
I'm the product manager for
Android Platform Security.
And today, in the next
section of the talk,
I'd like to give you an
overview of the changes
that we've made to the operating
system to make it more secure
as well as to harden it.
We've collected a lot
of data on the impact
and the adoption of
some of these features.
So I'm excited to share
some of that with you.
So let's dig in.
We'll start with the basics.
And that begins
with Verified Boot.
So Verified Boot is Android's
secure boot mechanism,
where we check the signature
of every stage of boot
before running it.
And that has come a long
way in the last few years.
With Android
Marshmallow, we started
requiring a Verified Boot
for all compatible devices.
With Android Nougat, that
became Verified Boot is now
strictly enforced.
And that's required for
all compatible devices.
And now, with Android O, we're
providing guidance to our OEM
ecosystem to add a couple
more security enhancements
to really round out the features
that have Verified Boot,
starting with
rollback protection.
On compatible
devices on Android O,
Verified Boot will no longer
boot an operating system
that's known to have been rolled
back to an older, potentially
much more vulnerable version.
Also with Verified
Boot, we have hardened
the unlocking mechanism, the
bootloader unlocking mechanism.
And what that means is
any bugs or any compromise
of the Android operating system
cannot unlock the bootloader.
Only you, by interacting
with the bootloader itself,
can unlock the bootloader.
So while Verified Boot
protects your operating system,
Android uses encryption
to protect user data.
And that has also come a long
way in the last few years.
As of Android Marshmallow,
all compatible devices
are now required to
support encryption
and required to be enabled by
default. As of Android Nougat,
we added a major upgrade
to the encryption story
called file-based
encryption, where
we encrypt different storage
areas with different keys.
File-based encryption
may the user experience
of encryption much, much better
without sacrificing security.
As an app developer
in fact, if you're
interested in running
your app before the user
first signs in-- before the
user first unlocks their device,
check out our FBE documentation
on our developer website.
With Android O, we have
continued to improve on FBE
and added in a few more
features such as key ejection.
So how are we doing
with encryption?
We looked into the data and see
that over the last few years,
encryption on Android--
we've seen a
significant adoption.
While it was on Android
Lollipop devices,
encryption was very, very low.
On Marshmallow, that
jumped to about 25%.
And now in Android Nougat,
we're seeing encryption support
at around 80%.
As a matter of fact, we
started requiring encryption
on compatible devices as
of Android Marshmallow.
The reason that number didn't
jump immediately to 100%
is due to a couple of factors.
One is a lot of
Marshmallow devices
were upgrades from Lollipop
and so those devices were not
required to be encrypted
when they first shipped.
And also, because
of the wide variety
of devices that are
supported by Android,
we still see a lot of very
low performance devices
that are not yet capable
of supporting encryption.
Nevertheless, we can expect that
number to continue to increase.
And we see that
encryption on Android
is now the norm and no
longer the exception.
Another way in which we
are protecting user data
is to improve the secure
lock screen experience.
With Android Marshmallow, we
introduced official support
for fingerprint sensors.
And that had a significant
impact on the adoption
rate of a secure lock screen.
Also, we have been
working with manufacturers
to put on requirements to
make the implementation
of a secure lock screen
much more secure over time.
From the very beginning,
fingerprint implementation,
the fingerprint
verification, was
required to be implemented
in secure hardware,
such as the Trusted Execution
Environment, the TEE.
With Android Nougat,
we started requiring
that pin pattern password
verification also
take place in secure hardware.
And now, with Android O,
we're adding in support
for tamper resistant hardware.
So similar to the chip that
you see in credit cards
today, Android now supports
having that chip be embedded
in the hardware and using that
chip to do pin pattern password
verification.
This significantly
raises the bar--
makes it much, much
harder to perform
a physical attack
against a device
to bypass the lock screen.
So how are we doing with
secure lock screen adoption?
We see that that has also
increased quite a bit
over the last few years.
Whereas on Lollipop
devices, adoption
was only about half and half,
that increased to almost 70%
now on new Android
Nougat devices.
And a lot of that was
probably driven by the fact
that a lot of new devices now
have a fingerprint sensor.
And we see from the data
that fingerprint devices
are much more likely
to have a secure lock
screen than across the
entire Android device
system, device market.
The other thing is that we do
see apps such as Android Pay
and some enterprise apps
require enabling a secure lock
screen to function properly.
So that might also
have had an effect.
As developers, you might want
to consider taking really
really take advantage
of a lock screen
and incorporating that
into your own application.
So we see a lot of banking
apps, for example, incorporating
fingerprint authentication.
So while encryption and lock
screen protects user data,
Android has a robust
permission model
to give users control over
app access to their data.
And that has also improved quite
a bit over the last few years.
With Android Marshmallow, we
introduced runtime permissions.
And we've seen great
adoption there.
With Android Nougat
and Android O,
we are continuing to update
the permissions model
to make it more
usable by good apps
and less abusable by bad apps.
So before we go into
the details of that,
let's check out how runtime
permissions are doing.
We looked into
permission requests.
And so for each
request for, let's say,
the camera group of permissions,
we see that about 65%
of those requests are
accepted by their users.
So that's towards one
end of the spectrum.
Towards the other
end of the spectrum,
we see that for the phone group
of provisions, only about 44%
of the permission requests
are accepted by the user.
So users are actually very
judicious in controlling which
apps have access to what data.
So I think there are a couple
of takeaways here for apps.
The big thing is, of course,
to follow a permissions best
practices, so you
can really take
advantage of runtime provisions
and provide the best user
experience.
As an example, you
should always make sure
that users know
why you're asking
for a particular
permission and be
able to fail gracefully if
they decline that permission
request.
In some cases, you may not
need to ask for permission.
For example, you may be able to
use the contacts picker instead
of requesting the
contacts permission.
Another way in which we are
updating our permissions model
is to make it less
abusable by bad apps.
So take ransomware
as an example.
We've seen instances
of this type of malware
that take over your device
and then demand payment
before they let you back in.
And they typically
abuse two permissions.
First, they use a system
alert window permission
to display an overlay on
top of your entire screen
so that you can't interact
properly with your device.
To address that, on Android
Oh, we have changed the system
alert window permission
slightly so that app overlays
can no longer cover up
critical system windows.
So they can no longer
cover up the lock screen.
They cannot cover
up the status bar.
They cannot cover up the IME--
as examples.
Also, when there is an app
overlay that's being shown,
there will also
be a notification
that users can click on to
hide that overlay window.
Ransomware also take advantage
of the device admin provision.
That they use it to
prevent their own uninstall
and they use it to
change your passcode
to lock you out of your device.
Over the last few years, we
have been continually descoping
the device admin
permission and replacing it
with a less abusable
alternative.
In particular, in
Android Nougat,
bad apps can now no longer use
the device admin permission
to prevent their own
uninstall and they
can't use it to change your
passcode if you already
have one set.
To learn more, we actually have
a talk one of our coworkers
gave at a different conference.
So check that out.
Another way in which we've
updated the permissions model
in order to protect users
is to take a stronger stance
on privacy.
Over the last few
releases of Android,
we've been steadily removing
access to persistent device
identifiers.
So for example on Android
O, the Android ID property
is now scoped per
user and per app.
The net.hostname property, which
contains the network hostname
of your device, is now empty.
To learn more about the
changes in Android O regarding
persistent device identifiers,
check out the blog post
that's on the screen.
That will tell you all the
changes as well as some best
practices.
So everything I've
talked about so far
relates to installed apps.
So what about Instant Apps?
If you guys were here
in the last session,
actually in this tent, there was
a session about Instant Apps.
So Instant Apps, for
those who don't know,
is a feature coming to Android,
where you can click on a URL
and open it immediately
in an Android app,
even if you don't have
the app installed.
So that has the potential to
greatly improve user experience
as well as increase an app's
user engagement and conversion
numbers.
On the other hand, opening
arbitrary URLs in apps
also comes with associated
security and privacy risks.
So how do we want
to address that?
We are addressing that by
creating an updated provisions
model that's really
tailored to the capabilities
and characteristics of
an Android Instant App.
In particular, Instant Apps
will have security and privacy
best practices baked in.
For example, Instant Apps
must use runtime provisions.
And Instant Apps will use HTTPS
instead of HTTP, by default.
There are a lot of Android
permissions that Instant Apps
actually cannot access.
They cannot access any
persistent device identifiers.
And another example is that
they can't access the contacts
permission.
You must use the
contacts picker instead.
As app developers, if
you make your normal app
deployable as an
Instant App, it actually
makes your normal
app much better too,
because you're now automatically
using security and privacy best
practices.
And for users, if the
majority of your apps
are now using these
best practices,
then your device becomes
a little bit safer too.
So we're very excited about
the Instant Apps model.
So while permissions
is really a way
to control app access to
data, within the operating
system itself we
sandbox and isolate
every process and
every app to limit
the ways in which a compromise
in one can affect the others.
For many years in Android, we
have been steadily improving
the application sandbox
in force with SELinux.
And we'll see how that's
doing in the next slide.
In Android Nougat, we
apply these same sandboxing
principles to the media server
to significantly harden it.
And now in Android O,
with Project Trouble,
we are taking isolation
to the next level
by putting device
specific vendor components
into their own sandboxes.
So how are we doing there?
We looked into the data, into
the Android security bulletin
data from the first four
months of this year.
We looked at all
the kernel bugs.
And we see that about
1/2 of the kernel bugs--
almost 1/2-- SELinux
actually reduced the severity
of almost 1/2 of
those kernel bugs.
By making parts of the kernel
unreachable by untrusted apps,
we made it so that it's
much harder to exploit
those parts of the kernel.
And that's what SELinux
really helps with.
As I mentioned earlier, we
took the same sandboxing
and isolation techniques and
applied it to the media server.
In older versions of
Android, the media server
used to be this one giant,
monolithic, very complex
process, that had access
to a lot of permissions.
In Android N, we broke that
up into six different policies
and put them into
individual sandboxes
with much tighter permissions
so that a compromise
to any one of them
only grants access
to a small subset
of the provisions
and not the permissions of
the entire media server.
We also integrated integer
overflow sanitization
into the media
server, where we're
able to detect memory
corruption that
results from integer overflows.
This helped us find a lot more
bugs earlier in the development
process and limited the
severity of any bugs that
occur at runtime.
So how did we do there?
We looked into the bugs, the
Android security bulletin bugs,
from the first four
months of this year.
And we see that
of all media stack
bugs that affected Android
Marshmallow, more than 20%
of them, actually, are no longer
security issues in Android N.
And a few more bugs on top of
that downgraded in severity
from Marshmallow to N.
And we're not done yet.
So in Android O, we took
the sandboxing isolation
to a whole new level
with Project Trouble.
With Project Trouble, we're
putting the Android OS
framework and the
vender implimentatino,
the device-specific
vendor implementation,
into different processes
that communicate
with each other using a
standard vendor interface.
This vendor interface will
be maintained from version
to version, which means
a newer Android OS
framework will run
with minimal changes
on top of an older device.
And that paves the way then for
us to release new Android OS
framework versions with shiny
new features and new security
enhancements and have it be
adopted much more quickly
by the entire ecosystem.
So that's very, very
exciting for security.
Also, the vendor
interface allows
us to enforce a boundary between
the framework and the vendor
implementation so
that we can use
it to limit the ways
in which a bug in one
can affect the other.
To take an example, let's
go back to the media server.
As part of Project Trouble, we
have re-architected the media
server again in Android O
and taken the audio, camera,
and DRM hardware
abstraction layers
and put them into
different processes
and different sandboxes.
What that lets us do is to say
the framework pieces actually
now no longer need
access to the kernel
components, the kernel drivers,
that control media playback.
And so now we can put
the framework pieces also
into tighter sandboxes
as well and make it so
that an exploit in the kernel,
compromising the kernel--
it's now much harder
for that compromise
to exploit certain
areas of the--
oh, sorry.
It's now harder for
compromises in the framework
to exploit certain
areas of the kernel.
All right, so speaking
of the kernel,
why is the kernel important?
In the last year,
we have spent a lot
of time hardening the kernel.
And we did that for
one major reason.
We see that kernel
bugs are becoming
a much larger proportion
of Android security bugs.
Whereas in 2014 about 4%
of Android security bugs
were kernel bugs, that number
increased significantly,
to about 44%.
And there are probably a
couple of reasons for this.
One is we've made
a lot of progress
in hardening the user space.
So for example, the
application sandbox--
that's enforced by SELinux.
That's gotten a lot
better over time.
And in order to break out
of that application sandbox,
in order to break out
of the SELinux sandbox,
you have to
compromise the kernel.
Also the kernel
is very powerful.
It has a large attack surface.
It's kind of like the king
piece in a game of chess.
You take the kernel
and you win the game.
And so we decided to spend
a lot more time thinking
about how to harden the kernel.
So we looked into what
causes kernel bugs.
We looked into the
data from 2014 and 2016
and categorized different kernel
bugs into different categories.
And we see that the largest
category, accounting
for about 45%, is this missing
and incorrect bounce check
when we're copying data from
userspace to the kernel.
So we presented
those exact same data
to the Linux upstream
community and to ARM last year.
And to their credit, they
were super responsive.
Within a couple of
months, they gave us
a feature called
harden user copy
that addresses this entire
category of kernel bugs.
So we have since then backported
harden user copy to the Android
kernels, 318 and above.
And we have also implemented
a few more security features
on top of that.
We have implemented
pan emulation.
KASLR and many others.
So all of these kernel
features, taken together--
we expect that they will have
a huge impact on the number
and severity of kernel
bugs in the future.
Another way in which we
are protecting the kernel
is to reduce its attack surface.
We're using a technology
called seccomp
to enforce a white
list of system calls
that apps can use to
communicate with the kernel.
Any system calls that are
not on that white list
will be blocked by
the seccomp filter.
So everything that's
on the white list--
that includes system
calls that are
made by all public libraries
that are supported in Android.
And we have tested many
of the top apps, as well
as Google Apps.
So we expect that this actually
won't impact almost any app.
But if you do have an app that
uses a lot of native code,
we do encourage you to test
that up on an Android O device
to make sure that
any system calls
that you make are not affected
by the new seccomp filter.
Having this white list
of kernel interfaces
allows us to really
focus and concentrate
our testing and
quality assurance
efforts on this
well-defined white list
and also be sure,
be more confident,
that the rest of the
kernel is protected
and that it's much harder to
exploit the rest of the kernel.
Seccomp is actually
not new to Android.
Chrome has been using it
for quite a while, in fact.
So Chrome has their own
app-defined seccomp filter
around their renderer process.
They use this seccomp filter
to make a few guarantees.
They want to guarantee that
the renderer process can
read global states, but it
can not modify a global state.
And in fact, this has been
quite useful quite a few times.
Recently, we've seen a few
kernel bugs that were actually
unreachable from the
Chrome renderer process,
because the relevant system
calls were blocked by seccomp.
OK, so that was a
really quick overview
of the security relevant
updates in the Android OS.
Let's now turn to app security.
In particular, we'll
talk about a couple
of features that improve
the security of your apps.
First, let's go over WebView.
So WebView has been with Android
since the very beginning.
Up until KitKat, it shipped
with the operating system,
which means that if there
were any bugs in WebView,
it actually was not very
easy for us to fix those bugs
and get them out
to users quickly.
We addressed that with Android
Lollipop when we made WebView
a separate APK
that is updateable
every six weeks
by the Play store.
And now, with Android O,
we've added quite a bit more--
a few more security
features to WebView.
In particular, the
WebView renderer process,
similar to how it
works on Chrome,
now runs as an isolated
process, separate
from the rest of your app.
This means that any crashes or
any compromises to the renderer
process no longer
really affects your app.
And any website that is able
to exploit the WebView process
can't easily use that to
exploit the rest of your app.
The renderer
process, in fact, is
put into a very, very
tight sandbox, using
seccomp and other technologies.
For example, it can not write
to the network on its own,
talk to the network on its own,
or write to disk on its own.
And so that also
protects the rest
of the operating system
from any exploits in WebView
in the renderer process.
Another cool feature coming
to WebView is Safe Browsing.
So Safe Browsing has
been available on Chrome
for quite a long time.
When users visit a web site
that's known to be malicious,
Safe Browsing will
show a warning
and prompt the user
before continuing.
Safe Browsing has been
showing useful warnings
to users more than 250
million times per month.
And now it's coming
to WebView on Android.
Safe Browsing is
actually implemented
within the WebView
APK that's updateable
every six weeks
by the Play store.
And so you can actually
change your app
and protect your users
almost immediately.
Another important
aspect of app security
is the device and
user authentication.
So why is device
authentication important?
Well if you're using
your phone to buy things
or to unlock your
home door, you want
to make sure that no one can
pretend to be your phone.
And so what you can do is you
can use the Android key store
APIs to generate a key pair to
uniquely identify your device.
The benefit of using
the key store APIs
is that on new Android
devices, key store keys
are protected by secure
hardware, such as the Trusted
Execution Environment.
And so even in the event
of a kernel compromise,
no one can extract
out those keys
and clone them onto
another device.
There was always one
question remaining though,
which is, how do you actually
know that those keys are
properly protected?
Let's say you're
on the server side.
How does your server
verify that you're
talking to a device that's
using keys that are properly
protected by secure hardware?
This is where key
attestation comes in.
With Android O, we're
adding in an attestation
API for compatible devices,
where at a high level
your server can talk directly
to the secure hardware,
the trusted execution
environment on the device,
and ask it to give
you signed assertions
about the properties of
the keys that it protects
as well as about the
properties of the device.
So for example, the
key attestation API
can tell you whether the key
itself actually is protected
by the secure hardware.
It can also tell
you, for example,
whether Verified Boot passed
on that particular device.
The associated attestations
certificate chain
on compatible
devices is actually
rooted in a Google certificate.
So that's how you know
that that device itself
is known to Google and is
compatible with Google's
standards.
All right, so that was
device authorization.
So what about user
authentication?
We're happy to let everyone
know that with the next version
of Google Play services, we're
also adding APIs to support
FIDO U2F security keys.
As you probably
know, security keys
are second factor
tokens that are already
accepted by many major
web sites such as Google,
Facebook, GitHub.
And security keys, as compared
to traditional second factor
methods, are faster
to authenticate
and harder to phish.
So we know that
for a lot of users,
one of the most important
things that they
can do to secure
their user account
is to enable second
factor authentication.
So we're very excited
that security key support
is coming to Android.
So to wrap up, we covered
a lot of material.
We talked about all
kinds of improvements
in the operating system.
We talked about app security.
If you want to learn more about
making your app more secure,
check out these
developer resources.
We have a checklist as well
as some best practices.
We also have a
couple of code labs
here at I/O that you can
try out at the kiosks
or you can try out online.
So thank you for your attention.
And if you have questions
or any comments,
feel free to email us
at security@android.com.
And we'll also be backstage.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]